the family that took in Nicholas Cruz
says they knew that he was depressed but
they had no idea how troubled he really
was James and Kimberly Sneed let Cruz
live in their house after his mom died
back in November Cruz was a friend of
their sons John Blackstone sat down with
this needs to ask about the 19 year olds
life and his history with guns the Nick
we knew was not to Nick that everybody
else seemed to know he pulled one over
on us as well as a lot of people Nicolas
Cruz had been living with the Sneed
family for about three months when he
allegedly carried out the deadliest
school shooting in Florida history and
how many guns did he have I'm not sure
five or six he was coming into your
house and you didn't know how many guns
he had I knew he had five or six I don't
know I don't know kind of work didn't
matter what kind of guns that were I
have guns
I respect guns as long as they're
handled properly simply safely and one
of the stipulations of him moving in is
to have a gun safe before he moved in so
you wanted him to have a gun safe but
you didn't know how many guns or what
kind of guns they were that he would be
putting in this I know he had hunting
rifles I thought they were just hunting
rifles well I knew he had a salt rifle I
knew it but I knew we used it out
hunting and that seems a reasonable
thing it's his right to a gun and you
thought it was fine for a 19 year-old
Devon ar-15 he this is right to have it
do you feel any differently about that
now no according to a Florida Department
of Children and Families report Cruz
suffered from depression ADHD and autism
between 2011 and 2016 Broward County
sheriff's deputies were called to Cruz's
mother's home 39 times several of them
allegedly due to Cruz's violent outburst
didn't worry you him having access to
guns no he was just depressed and we
thought he was just oppressed over his
his mother's death were there any signs
of trouble beyond his depression yeah
we've had him on a positive path and you
know when turning to heal and he just
blew it I mean it isn't just Florida we
had no idea absolutely
Florida absolutely poor well his future
really the future of 17 others and their
families their families their very self
affect do you feel any responsibility
for that that's all we feel heartfelt
sorrow for the families involved as far
as being responsible feeling
responsibility you know we work that out
and there was nothing different we would
have done
James need also told John Blackstone he
thought there was only one key to the
gun safe where he made crews keep his
weapons but Sneed now believes there
were actually two keys and Nicolas Cruz
had the other interesting interview to
hear their perspective on all of this
yeah it is